hey Exiles how we doing Mr a2g back
again playing some more Saga of survival
all right we're going to do something a
little bit uh different today I want to
explain as best as I can um about the
new adventurers Quest that's come
through so we only got a little bit
about it in the patch notes saying that
you know every so often on your daily
rewards uh you've got the ability to
claim for you know uh this one here so
the adventurer Airship basically it's a
limited time uh zone so we've only got a
certain amount of time to go into the
Zone see what it's all about uh fulfill
the quest and then obviously move on
claim the rewards all that sort of stuff
then we've got another one here a little
bit further down on day seven on my end
here whether that matches up with you
guys or it's a little bit indifferent um
your mileage May differ to mine so I've
already claimed for it and we're going
to go ahead and activate that and we're
going to get right into it and we'll see
what it's all about I'll take you
through it and hopefully we'll get it
wrapped up um pretty soon soon now
before you guys go ahead and uh jump on
to the Overworld there to see where it
is you need to claim for it so by doing
that you need to go into your Vault
scroll down until I've got a lot of
stuff in here by the way um until you
actually find it so you'll find it in a
moment's time there we go so you got the
Airship Adventure here so you just want
to go ahead and claim and let's see if
that pops up in our infantry or does it
pop up on the map let's find
out okay so it's there so we go use
Limited Time Adventure has begun so I'm
assuming that might be the same thing
for the um for the next adventure quest
as well uh but for now we'll just roll
with this Adventure Quest and see what
this one's all about it should populate
on our Overworld map there we go so
limited time and Adventure a stranger uh
sorry a strange thing came down from the
sky and AIT go help the pilot
well let's go ahead and do that so he's
just situated over
here and we'll run in we'll see what
it's all about so it's not a particular
too U too difficult of a zone so one and
1 half skulls what I've got here is
completely overpowered for the job um
you know at hand I could even just use
my pyro ring that I've got uh stored
here I've brought an Axe and a pickaxe
just in case if there's anything that I
need to harvest over there and see what
we can get um the loot have a look at
the loot table there didn't appear that
there was too much out of that so um I
think there was just a little bit of um
basic resources so we'll just quickly go
ahead and have a look at that if I can
ever so tight slightly tap on it so
possible loot we've got a purple star
Skillet some oil uh The Amulet the
necklace uh some books there Oak plank
belts and bless water so we'll just jump
back right in I should have done that
first my bad guys all right guys make
sure you guys like like the video if you
did enjoy this one here and go ahead and
do the usual things comment down below
hit the like button subscribe all that
sort of good stuff um oh you just the
sort of person I need my a ship ran into
some trouble uh no sooner did I bring
her to rest did Goblin steal my supplies
and escape to the swamp bring back my
things and I'll give you my lucky
Skillet what do you say so we've got to
find these items throughout the zone
uh and we got a l okay so we might have
to find it on one of the Goblins there
maybe or something in a in a chest
something or other but to be perfectly
honest all these little materials here
I'm hoping we'll probably find it all in
the zone if not I know I've got it
everywhere so we'll go ahead and um sus
it all out here so we'll probably just
grab some uh wood as well while we're
doing a little uh
questing if it wants to chop down there
we go so that's the six pine log
there we go yeah guys so um just sort of
let you know out of courtesy um I think
at the time of this video I should be
five subscribers away from hitting my
first th000 uh sub Subs so it is it's
been a massive Milestone um that I've
been wanting to achieve for such a long
time and we are so close um yeah look
I'm not going to ask for subscribers
just for the sake of um you know if you
guys are doing it uh to get me there
look I want I rather earn it and do it
the right way if you guys do enjoy my
content and you don't want to miss out
on any future videos then please hit
that sub button if not um that's all
good just hit the like button if you
enjoyed it you know just get it up the
recommended uh recommended page that's
all I asked for on that one there um
otherwise you know what just enjoy the
videos guys hear my love lovely voice
all that sort of good stuff all right so
with that out of the way I'm going to
keep going so we'll grab some of this
and how much wood did we have we have 18
so I need a little bit more wood so I'll
just grab one of
there and let's see what this area has
we got a couple first
frogs and does that no it does not okay
take out the goblin completed a quest
very good ooh got the little um a little
scroll there okay we'll s that out in a
sec and what's out of here anything
interesting I'll take that o look at
that got the berry
tea if thank you game if you can allow
me to actually tap on things that would
be
great um all right what do we got what
do we got anything up here don't think
so we'll quickly just scan the area
around and anything of Interest not so
much I'll just grab that while we're at
it
anything down this way nope dead
end so it doesn't look to be a
particularly uh massive
map we just take out these
guys oh okay so these guys are coming up
with swamp Okay swamp map section town
to piece used to navigate to the swamp
Okay so looks like they might have there
might be a few that we need to check out
uh so a few little you know map
coordinates once we've got the required
amount I'm assuming it's going to piece
together and we can uh jump into the uh
the swamp uh area and hopefully um we'll
be able to um find uh the lever I take
it in this situation I think that's
probably going to be what we're needing
to look for I'm not going to worry about
the clay at this point I've got so much
clay now ever since this new update
that's dropped I've got so much clay I
it's I'm going to clay bar for days that
that's basically what I'm saying um I'm
not going to need to you know hunt
certain zones or anything like that what
problem
hey you're a little bit
different and why didn't I kill you in
the first
place take all
that and what have we got here nothing
there nothing
there um I wonder if that's
enough I wonder if that is
enough well that's a point of Interest
by the looks of things just want to see
okay I did Kill everything
there
okay oh okay so I've got all three
claim
nice and assuming that's going to take
us to the swap which it does nice and
easy there we
go and that will probably take us back
to where we came from let's take out
these guys I hate these things they they
put they put your curse points so high
up
cuz now if you look at the left hand uh
part of the screen where my avatar is uh
you'll notice that I've got curse points
times three so you just want to be
careful with
that and I'll just grab all of
this so this is um so little drop um you
know little chest and things like that
kind of like in the the two skull zones
that you'll
find so you might get like little gifts
and things like that
raw materials whatever it might be
so all right let's see what we got out
of this one
rets get rid of that mosquito
bed and there's another one there I'm
just going to go ahead and hit it I'm
it's annoying that they don't come up
actually on the map so you can't
actually see them but I guess that's the
whole point of it you know you got to be
careful you have your wits about
you okay there's that hot bed take that
out oops no no no grab the barrel we'll
see what's in the barrel here and
hopefully we might find what we're
looking
for I'll take those
Scrolls what I might actually do cuz I
did bring the horse
today let's grab that and
that and all the other bits and pieces
that I may not need probably that that
and there's
that and you know what I probably don't
even need that today
cuz I want to grab that and that
perfect get that yellow
spider didn't give me anything thank you
very
much okay did you give me something nope
okay all right so I'm just going to do a
quick
scan there we go something I didn't want
to happen it
happened that is totally
fine so I'll just grab one of those and
we are
back grab some of
that okay so we got a mixture of frogs
in here so you got the cursed frog dark
frog okay take out you take out you
definitely okay I think I've got more
than enough um cheese cloths there so I
don't think I need any more but
anyway okay let's see what's coming out
of here
grab some of that I'll take that
definitely take
that okay that
and you and you as
well and there's no rope usually you
guys drop
rope okay well that's back to where we
came from there was a little section
there I didn't cover so we'll go through
there
now and I didn't see that that
okay so a bit of charcoal Goblin leader
do you have my leather uh lever
lever I don't know why I said leather
anyway H it's too early in the morning
my time here
guys take the nails I do need the nails
actually and one more J there we go
take out you and I think that did say
swamp Goblin it did okay so
hopefully okay I think I've noticed that
in the update let me know if you guys
did where your character didn't actually
you didn't see the
animation uh to him actually attacking
but yet you'd actually see the enemy
health bar reduced yeah let me know if
you'd actually seen that or if you've
experienced
that okay well see now he's doing it
actually another thing to note as well
just using my crossbow I feel that it's
a lot slower than um in the previous uh
update o dark swamp Goblin okay you're
going to have to have what I
need just take out that hot
bed let's take out the other hot bed I
just want to take that out yeah so I
think the time delay is a lot more on
the crossbow than it was in the previous
update I don't know if it's just me I
don't know if you guys have experienced
that too I want you to let me know in
the comments down
below yes okay cool so you've got what I
need I don't need that I'm going to grab
that I don't need any of that I'll just
leave that
behind loot up the chest and I think
that's probably going to go ahead and
call it I guess we well you know I'll
see what else is need I think we need
some raw meat which I didn't get from
this Z so I know I've got that at home
which is not a problem at all
okay um what do I give
up I guess I'll use that take
that use that and take that there we
go and we did loot that didn't we yeah
we did okay so I think that's it we'll
go sus out
now the rest of
everything actually I think I I think I
do definitely need some meat so let's
let's quickly go back home I'll grab the
meat cuz I think that's all I
need and we'll um yeah we'll finish off
this quest for the um for today's
video okay sorry I just had a bit of
coffee and let's jump back
in go
and you know what for now I just might
dump some of that over here and
there and let's just grab the meat I
think that's it honestly I think that is
but we'll have a
look don't want to make a you know
complete round trip for everything
so it's a good little Quest I mean you
know just something to break up uh the
norm the mold if you will gives you
something uh to do and you got a decent
amount of time so I don't see why not
that you guys couldn't complete it um
you should be able to it it's it appears
very easy I don't know what it's going
to be for the next um for the next
mission um that we'll have but we'll
we'll obviously work it out when the
time comes all right so let's go ahead
and claim everything so we need that
that that that that and that
claim that's it that's it so he's not
going to so we can't interact with him
anymore um as I said we've only got a
day a little bit over a day for that to
um for this Zone to leave but let's go
ahead and check out the the skillet pan
going to swap them over so we have 20
attack damage 16 wall uh 32 awareness
1.2 oh sorry um yeah and then over 500
uh hit points on it which is not bad you
know what I think this probably be
arguably a decent um uh melee weapon
just for you know one to two skull zones
if you really wanted to use it and you
don't want to use any decent weapons or
anything like that I think this would be
your go-to um if you want to sort of you
know keep it and retain it you probably
just want to invest in some uh repair
hammers just to get it back up to
scratch that's obviously up to you guys
but that's what I'm thinking about that
it's probably going to be a decent
Handler for um for those type of zones
but I think we're going to go ahead and
leave it today it's just a really quick
one just wanted to give you a quick
overview on how that works and um yeah
shed some lot because unfortunately in
the patch notes of the developers didn't
really elaborate on it so I figured you
know what let's drop this in and
hopefully you guys enjoyed anyway if you
guys are new if you guys enjoyed the
content if you want to watch more if you
want to keep up a date go ahead and hit
that subscribe button along with that
notification Bell so you don't miss on
any future videos like and comment as
always guys all right take it easy catch
you next time